le dossier commençait à sentir très
mauvais en 2013 une compagnie privée
située à whitby en ontario expédie une
centaine de conteneurs aux philippines
censé contenir des plastiques destinés
au recyclage
mais surprise les autorités philippines
découvre que ce n'est pas le cas il y
avait des bouteilles des sacs de
plastique mais aussi des ordures
ménagères manie n'entend pas à rire donc
bassorah la gamme halal le président
rodrigo doute rt menace de déclarer la
guerre au canada s'il ne récupère pas
ses ordures
des manifestations ont lieu devant
l'ambassade du canada
c'est la honte le canada décide
finalement d'agir la situation a duré
trop longtemps selon le premier ministre
justin trudeau
la ministre de l'environnement a donc
annoncé qu'elle donnait le contrat cette
entreprise française bolloré installé à
montréal pour rapatrier et disposer de
ces ordures gênante
la ministre des affaires internationales
travaillent également sur le dossier
le canada travaille en étroite
collaboration avec les philippines pour
finir pour résoudre la situation
cette situation plus qu'embarrassante
pour le canada est un signal d'alarmé
très sérieux selon équiterre on a une
opportunité ici de revoir tout le
système c'est un peu honteux pour le
canada et beaucoup de gens qui savent
pas que nous
richer matières recyclables ou pas
circulent un peu partout sur la planète
il faut dire aussi que les ordures se
rapporte comme le rappelle madame fort
les déchets c'est vraiment une grande
business il ya des courtiers
il ya très peu de transparence mais les
courtiers qui vont faire la transaction
sa potro ou vont aboutir à ces déchets
coût de l'opération 1 million 143 milles
dollars et c'est le gouvernement
canadien qui va défrayer la note
c'est le prix à payer pour garder de
bonnes relations avec les philippines et
son président ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal